here's the big story senator lucas
charged with two felonies for june
incident at the portsmouth confederate
monument
this is out of virginia this was back in
june we've seen a wave
of these you guys know this the riots
where they're going in they're tearing
down statues well
now the hammers is being is dropping we
got two big stories about people being
arrested for it
the crazy thing about this one is that
this lady is actually an elected
democrat
they say the portsmouth police chief
angela green announced during a monday
afternoon press conference
that state senator louise lucas has been
charged with two felonies for an
incident at the city's confederate
monument
on june 10th she among others is facing
charges of conspiracy to commit a felony
an injury to a monument in excess of one
thousand dollars
portsmouth officials held the briefing
monday afternoon to announce that
several warrants have been secured
against individuals
more than two months after the incident
at the city's confederate monument so it
sounds like it's not just her
it's gonna be a bunch of other people
green issued a statement
but did not take any questions as the
investigation is ongoing city officials
said
on june 10th the confederate monument
was vandalized and broken apart by
protesters
which culminated with a protester being
seriously injured
when part of the statue fell on him so i
remember this did you do you ever see
the story
no they pulled the statue down on the
dude's head i saw that
yep yep this is why i always try to tell
my friends when they're complaining
about i want you progressive friends and
they'll be like
well they're confederate statues you
know and my response is always
it fell on someone's head you know look
if you want to remove it i get it but
at the very least you've got to have
some kind of safe
uh honestly even after it happened
people weren't crowding around
helping it seemed like people were still
just sort of standing there
like oh did that just hit somebody but
still like not
immediately going to help them yeah
that's because they're not paying
attention and they're just
throwing ropes and pulling it down and
they're i think they're emulating what
they see in like the middle east and
other countries
and so none of them really know what
they're doing it's just
it's all fun and games and then people
get seriously hurt
that's really a little bit more they say
since then a team of investigators
compiled evidence including video from
that day as a result of the
investigation detectives determined
that several individuals performed
felonious acts
and have taken out warrants against them
including lucas as well as a portsmouth
school board member wow lakeisha s
clue atkinson members of the naacp and
members of the public defender's office
wait wait wait
whoa they took wait hold on they got
warrants against members of the naacp
and the yeah no no this is wrong i'm
reading this wrong aren't they
no yeah several individuals performed
felonious acts even the public
defender's office
wow man i didn't realize that
the initial source i had was the hill i
like to pull up the original sources
though
and then i go through i'm like yep this
all adds up wow
so they have a full press conference on
it here's here's the full list of those
facing charges
of conspiracy to commit a felony an
injury to a monument in access of one
thousand dollars
state senator louise lucas james boyd of
the naacp louis gibbs and double acp
uh then we have lacesha hicks and double
naacp
lakeisha s clue a school board member
these next people i'm not gonna name
because it doesn't really say anything
about what they do but check this out
here's the list of individuals facing a
felony charge of injury to a monument
in axes of one thousand dollars brenda
spry public defender alexander stevens
public defender
meredith kramer public defender wow man
now my mind is blown that's crazy wow
dude green asked that anyone with an
active warrant turn themselves in
public defenders the police department
is asking for help identifying 13
additional people
detectives are asking the public take a
look at these photos and reach out if
you recognize them
call the portsmouth crime line wow man
the hammer is falling you you've been
seeing a lot about this right i mean
it's been happening in my town
you it seems so unnecessary because
towns are voting to take down the
statues
so if it's you don't need to tear it
down like
it seems like some plenty of legal votes
happening to take some of them some of
them they keep defending the statues
but you know what you know what really
bothers me is the whole conversation has
been nothing but
confederate that that's all i hear like
there's
there's so you know what i you know what
i always see and
i don't i don't know if you can answer
to this or like add to this as like
someone who runs social network
on facebook i get inundated with these
memes
and the left has these memes it's like
it seems to be where they get their news
i mean factually there was a study done
by a group called newswhip that found
the left gets their news from occupy
democrats which is a meme farm
whereas the right it's fox news which is
just conservative news source
so there's a meme right now where it's
like here's why
trump and the republicans are defending
confederate statues and these memes go
viral and it's all people see
when the real argument is actually about
george washington
ulysses says grant hans christian hegg
and about
not committing felonies because
sometimes statues fall in people's heads
so i don't know you know if
just in terms because maybe we should
say this for more the censorship segment
but
i mean facebook's only feeding people
this fake news you know what i mean
yeah the the statues
need to be re-contextualized
so that people can understand their
place in history
and time and like there's just other
ways
to do it well i mean like i guess what i
was trying to ask is about
how do we get people to realize actually
look i'll show you this this is what i
was trying to get to
six black lives matter protesters are
arrested for tearing down and defacing
george washington statue at la city hall
as cops recover gas mask
laser pointer helmets goggles arm
protectors and chain uh and change of
clothing to conceal identity
that first of all they're rioters but i
guess the the what i was trying to get
to is we have all these news stories
about how they're tearing down actual
founding fathers
but whenever you go on social media you
just see the left sharing memes about
confederate statues
right it made that leap and nobody
really acknowledged it trump did
and when he did the media lied and said
confederate confederate confederate
now i think i know the media does it
they don't they don't want to admit
that they entertained these these these
riots
and now they're tearing down george
washington but i guess
i guess my question to you if you can
speak to this is
how do we break that where the left only
sees
the fake news you know what i mean right
it's like building echo chambers how to
break echo chambers
so you need to
i i do believe in chronological feeds i
in a sense i believe in being able to
create
having the right to be able to create
your own echo chamber and not forcing
people to see stuff
that they don't want to see but i
personally like to
break my own echo chamber and i think
providing tools to
let people see the other side is super
important so i mean there are there
could be mechanisms for that
the the issue i see with facebook is
that while i agree with you
you know i follow who i want to follow
and yeah i think
if you're a smart reasonable person
you're trying to follow as many
different voices as possible
right twitter periodically will switch
me back to algorithmic mode
so so i'll just try and explain this for
those that aren't familiar uh you said
you said reverse chronological yes
that's basically whoever you follow when
they post you see it
what all of these sites have been trying
to have been changing to like youtube
included is algorithmic
meaning they're going to show you what
they think you want to see
or is that is that the right way to
explain it yeah what they know
you're more likely to engage with yeah
so sometimes it's fake news
it's just so annoying on twitter like
they they revert you back every time
there's that little star
icon on the top and so you can go over
to chronological
i mean a lot of sites don't even allow
you to do that but you know people are
just not
going to click that button very i have
to check every so often
man do i get angry because for me it's
really important following news
that i get the latest news up to date
and then yeah every so often i'll be
like that's strange didn't this story
happen a day ago
you son of a and then i gotta click it
and switch it back they won't let you
keep it
right it keeps trying to switch it on
you so so listen in
in reference to what we're seeing here
there's two big things that i that i
think we get
as to why a woman would tear down this
you know face felony charges
first i'll say this she's 76
she probably thought i'll go to prison
whatever
you know it's it's i'm 76 what else am i
going to do
tear it down and now there you go right
yeah younger people they got their whole
lives ahead of them so that you know the
older activists probably jump in
but i think a lot of these younger
people because they're only seeing what
they want to see
they go out and they join these you know
these riots and they
they they end their lives like i mean
like with prison
do you see what happened in new york
with the molotov cocktail couple
no i know this is out of your wheelhouse
you're a social media guy so i'm just
gonna you know i guess
talk at you for a second there's a
couple people they uh they had molotovs
their two lawyers
early 30s pull up launch them at police
vehicles hand them out or
something that affect now their lives
are over a lot of these people are going
to prison
and they're getting wrapped up in this
like
fake i i call it a paranoid delusional
state
but which people are getting let off
like what is the
consensus around which states and cities
are just
letting the writers off versus not
well i guess if you throw a molotov
you're not getting one
yeah new york let a bunch of people go
for low-level protest defenses like
violating covet lockdown
dallas uh not dallas uh fort worth i i'm
pretty sure they're different uh release
people for literal rioting charges i
think some of these may have been
felonies
and then in portland they're just
straight up like you can go
just yes yeah that is causing their
police force to quit in mass right
and isn't their public defender friend
with antifa dude
i said something like that the portland
public defense well he did an interview
apparently
the portland public defender did like an
interview on some far left show
talking about how he's going to be
releasing these people so i think you
see
you know with i'm sorry man i didn't i
didn't realize public defenders like
this is this is crazy these are people
in government
who are breaking the law tearing things
down it's like the rule of law is just
crumbling
and i i think it has a lot to do with
only being fed
certain information because we've
actually talked about this quite a bit
over the past week
if the only thing people see is far left
then that's the only direction they can
go you know so it's kind of like covid
where you keep getting in inundated with
news about how the world is ending
and no one can see otherwise so then
businesses stay locked down facebook got
exposed for the
princeton secrets princeton study they
did trying to alter people's moods
what yeah they this was like five years
ago but basically
they without telling anybody injected
both positive and negative
emotional content into people's feeds
and found that they could change their
emotions i remember what they fed to
them dude and
so yeah obviously what you consume is
what you become
unless you make sure to consume
a diverse amount of content yeah well
but on facebook it's not
i mean you sort of can't you can't
because
out of the look i'm on facebook for me
i'm maxed out because i just i get so
many friends requests friend requests
you can't even i don't even think you
can actually request you're so cool dude
yeah yeah yeah it's you know some people
don't do this
they just deny everybody make their
accounts private so it's only their
friends and family
very early on i didn't care and start
hitting accept so now my feed is just
random garbage
and i you know what i see it more than
anything though i almost exclu i would
say 80 percent of the memes i see
are left-wing fake news conspiracy stuff
things like
you know there there there's one going
around from occupied democrats
i think i think it's not good by
democrats saying not a single democrat
is for open borders wants to take away
your guns
or you know you know it's trying to kill
babies or whatever
and i'm like i don't know yeah i was
like not a single democrat wants
non-citizens to vote and i'm like
all of these things are very easily
disproven with like mainstream
acceptable sources
that say yeah there are democrats who
want these things
but then i i personally only see on
facebook
well i should say only but like 80 of
the time the memes are left wing
very few right wing maybe that says
something about what i interact with so
you know you know what it might be i'm
like commenting it's not true so then
facebook just sends me more of the same
well there's no way we can know because
we have no idea what the algo is doing
so it's just i mean thousands of
variables are determining
what you're seeing and for sure they're
punishing
memes they can even read the language in
the meme without any text associated
with it with all of their
yeah you know image recognition there's
a uh
for youtube you can put an image i
forgot what it's called you know what
it's called
the google program where you put an
image search no no no you you can load
an image
and then it will read any text found in
the image yeah
so they're they're shadow banning memes
by detecting the language and the the
symbolism
in it like do you use just happening do
you think
that facebook is intentionally
manipulating information for political
or financial reasons yes but i
will caveat that with it is weird
that there are you know peter thiel's on
their board
yeah who's you know but for trump right
yeah he's anti-sjw for sure
yeah so it's not black and white like
these companies like there's warfare
happening within
these these companies but i think it's
clearly dominated by
super draconian content policies that
don't
allow a huge spectrum of speech it's not
just against conservative it's also
against you know anti-authoritarian
progressives lgbtq
anti-war um any sort of
more edgy material so it's you know
people like to
i i would agree that the conservatives
get the brunt
but it's not that black and white for
sure yeah yeah there's there was a a
report by project veritas
that found it's it's pronounced live
action right it's live action yeah i
tell you so
yeah live action is a pro-life
organization
they were being just outright censored
on pinterest
veritas released this doc this blacklist
document and they also had anti-media
which is a progressive anti-war you know
for the most part anti-police brutality
and i saw that too and i'm like
this is interesting because a lot of
occupy occupy wall street accounts got
shut down too
so it's not just conservatives it's
basically anti-establishment
yeah the anti-media crew i i knew them
they
wrote you know they were very diligent
in writing articles like you know maybe
they got some things wrong but like
those guys worked hard
but why why why blacklist anyone yeah
you know exactly
you subscribe get the content
like just let me decide
who i'm seeing and if they're annoying
me i can unfollow them it's just that
simple like you need that option but
that sounds naive
oh they know that yeah i'm not trying to
drag you i'm saying like
they these companies they know this
they're doing it because it empowers
them
yeah you know thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you